peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en sommes-nous derniers soubresauts du
drame algérien à oran où le calme s'est
rétabli après les dernières
manifestations dramatique de la semaine
passée les forces de l'ordre se sont mis
en devoir de passer au crible la ville
quartier par quartier les perquisitions
systématiques pratiqué par les gendarmes
et les crs qui avait déjà permis
l'arrestation de l'ex général jouhaud le
second de salles en ont fait découvrir
différents dépôts d'armes dont certains
étaient d'importance celui ci par
exemple qui comprenait sans fusil de
guerre et 10 mitrailleuse avec leur
canon de rechange
[Musique]
alger les années en militaires étaient
rendus aux douze soldats et gendarmes
tués par un commando aux assauts début
de la révolte de bab el-oued le général
ailleret est allé s'incliner devant ces
victimes du doigt
un bel oued se réveillaient lentement de
sa torpeur après un blocus de cinq jours
les fouilles avaient amené plus de 3000
arrestations
mais aux traces laissées par le combat
sont venus depuis s'ajouter d'autres
ruines l'immeuble du mauritanien où
étaient installés les services d'air
france a été endommagé par une explosion
massive
[Musique]
dans les rues les tristes vestiges du
combat sont encore en place comme un
douloureux rappel est une leçon tragique
les il ya à nouveau de la vie leur de
l'apaisement arrive-t-elle enfin
l'heure de l'apaisement avec leur de
l'espérance une espérance que chaque
français va sans doute fixé avec le
bulletin qu'il déposera dans l'urne du
référendum
[Applaudissements]
éteindre l'énorme fuite de gaz qui brûle
dans le désert de gassi touil il est un
travail d'hercule il fallait entre
autres à porter de touggourt les
soixante mille tonnes de baryte qui
seront déversés au moment où la flamme
sera soufflée par explosion
ce transport exceptionnel a pu être
menée à bien grâce au cargö du désert
que sont les camions géante et sans dont
les 700 chevaux et les roues
impressionnante se joue des difficultés
du terrain insensible qu'ils sont à tous
les pièges des sables à chaque navette
une bagatelle de 400 km à travers les
dunes les camions t100 ont amené à pied
d'oeuvre chacun 55 tonnes de bari
moyennant quoi l'heure approche où l'
incendie de gassi touil sera jugulée
[Musique]
un article porte de l'étang de berre les
automobilistes sont aujourd'hui
reconnaissant à la technique moderne qui
a lancé le nouveau pont mobile à
commande automatique de la jonquère la
circulation stoppé il ne faudra plus en
effet que 30 secondes à l' ouvrage pour
s'ouvrir de sa cabine à écran de
télévision l'opérateur n'a même pas
acheter un oeil sur le pont lui-même
l'important trafic de pétroliers vers
l'étang de berre zone en plein
épanouissement y trouve les mêmes
avantages de rapidité que la circulation
routière entre marseille et arles
autrefois stopper une demi heure à
chaque manoeuvre du vieux pots et puis
le nouveau pont enlève un record qui
n'est pas sans mérite il est sans doute
le plus élégant d'europe
[Musique]
en inaugurant la plus belle et la plus
complète exposition de l'art mexicain
que paris ait jamais vu monsieur andré
malraux a ouvert plus grande aux yeux
sur cette extraordinaire civilisation
aztèque dont les pyramides et les
sculptures nous remplissent toujours
d'étonnement ce qu'il faut de préférence
noter dans cette réunion de quelque 3000
pièces c'est surtout peut-être ces
figures féminines d'une aisance et d'un
délicat maniérisme comparable aux
figures crétoise pour certaines d'une
humanité hautaine et religieuses pour
d'autres mais qui tout nous donne un
aspect jusqu'ici mal entrevues des
civilisations qui se succédèrent dans
l'ancien mexique
chose assez étrange ces visages dont on
a trop souvent vu que le tragique savez
sourire et même ce sourire sur ces
visages de pierre suite aller jusqu'au
rire avant ou en même temps peut-être qu
entrer dans le coeur de ses peuples le
féroce visage de la mort
le monde artistique célèbre cette année
un compositeur français et paris n'a pas
manqué de lui rendre hommage darius
milhaud pour son 70e anniversaire vient
de diriger 4 de césaire ses 70 ans on
peut dire que darius milhaud les à
consacrer entièrement à la musique
puisque si on en croit sa vocation date
de l'âge de 3 ans entre sa femme et son
fils il n'hésite pas à avouer qu'il est
heureux qu'il l'a toujours été
et les souvenirs qu'ils remuent en
atteignant ses 70 ans sont des souvenirs
heureux ce sont ceux de 1911 à aix en
provence entre ses parents qui avaient
tout fait pour aider sa vocation précoce
ceux d'une distribution des prix au
brésil en 1910 est ce encore d'une fête
foraine en 1919 1920 c'était le groupe
des six adecco rick poulain que naguère
germaine tailleferre satie sans oublier
le septième perpétuelle manager
agitateurs des arts jean cocteau
la fête foraine était toujours au goût
du jour
1948 le retrouve aux côtés d'andré
maurois et fernand léger
1952 les six se sont retrouvés plus un
il retrouve une guerre
est aussi un grand inspirateur paul
claudel puis il stravinsky mes 70 ans
dit il ne sont pas différents de mes 50
mais ce qui me reste raccourci
[Musique]
cap et chapeau melon c'est ainsi que
daniel hechter couturier le 23 ans voit
les lycéennes aujourd'hui d'une
collection insolite qu'il a présentée
dans la rue en compagnie d'une consoeur
martin grand bal qui elle habille les
hommes on retiendra qu'à 16 ans le pull
à col roulé ne sera plus incompatibles
avec le deux pièces classiques
mais à la vérité les collégiennes n'ont
pas attendu que la mode leur arrive tout
près elles ont déjà fait elles mêmes
leurs moeurs
il suffit pour s'en rendre compte
d'assister à une sortie d'un lycée
parisien à hassine comme elle vise ou à
molières
de 13 à 17 ans on a des idées qui ne
sont pas celles de la grande soeur et on
les exprime pour commencer on a emprunté
les bretelles de papa unis de radier en
élastique en cuir ou en tissu elles ont
éliminé les ceintures
du grenier on a sorti une ancienne
trousses de médecins de campagne pourra
faire un sac
[Musique]
les bottes plus haute se portant d'un
orné d'une chaîne concurremment avec les
chaussures plates
les jupes sont volontiers comme la
grande folie les chaussettes emprunter
ou frère a sorti des chaussures
cyclistes
et bien sûr on ne lésine pas sur les
bijoux les colliers sont faits d'une
quantité de scènes très fine plus en
porte deux rangs plus c'est beau
les coiffures gonflante ont disparu la
vague eto'o ne poser comme des papillons
sur le sommet du crâne telle est la
nouvelle élégance des mois de 17 ans qui
fait fureur ont sans doute avec ces
tendances générales et variations de
détails c'est ainsi qu'aux chaînes
collier s'ajoutent volontiers en sautoir
la montre et l'alliance de grand mère
reste que le sacs sacoches le gros
bracelets au bras le pantalon type marin
qu'on appelle du reste la marine est les
bottes les chaussettes les chaussures
cyclistes et jupe à bretelles
constituent les éléments clés d'une note
qui ne suis pas à la mode mais dont les
créateurs de mode devront finalement
tenir compte c'est la revanche des moins
de 16 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque année à la même époque de tous
les coins de grande bretagne par
dizaines de milliers les britanniques
viennent à un tri pour assister au
massacre on appelle cela pudiquement le
grand national de liverpool par pure
hypocrisie de fait il s'agit de la plus
belle hécatombe qui se puisse barre sur
un champ de plus à chaque des jockeys ou
chevaux il ans disparaît toujours
quelques-uns seuls le cheval edison
semble se jouer de tous les obstacles
[Musique]
tous sauf cette petite faute lui coûte
la victoire il va disparaître
successivement dépassé par quatre
adversaires
car aussi bizarre qu'il y paraisse après
tant de chute il reste encore assez de
chevaux pour que ferait descendre
termine à la cinquième place
[Musique]
et c'est finalement qu'il manque qui
remporte cette année le grand national
de liverpool
[Musique]
c'est sans grande passion que se sont
déroulées les demi finales de la coupe
de france de football le match vedette
la rencontre angers saint-etienne au
parc des princes à paris les angevins
jouent en blanc comme le real madrid
mais la comparaison s'arrête là de fait
ce match ne va durer qu'une mi-temps
cours de laquelle les stéphanois
dominent leurs adversaires par des
actions plus ample et mieux souder et
surtout à saint-etienne on tire souvent
tendues et pas toujours efficaces mais
cela finit par être payés
et puis il suffit parfois d'un seul but
pour gagner un match c'est exactement le
cas des stéphanois qui jouera donc la
finale
aller nancy c'est en quelque sorte un
symbole qui a porté chance au joueur
l'ancien elle aussi en maillot blanc il
dit s'en aller sans trop de conviction
mais avec assez d'astuces pour battre le
football club de metz un peu malchanceux
il est bon les joueurs messins ont
souvent dominé dans un adversaire au
cours de la partie mais les efforts
platonique en football ne paie pas à
preuve c'est nancy qui gagne par 1 but à
0 et qui jouera la finale contre
saint-etienne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans son ensemble la population a
répondu à l'appel aux young du
référendum et elle a donné au général de
gaulle le oui massif qu'il avait demandé
à la nation ce oui populaire d'année à
la paix des accords d'evian le président
de la république l'a concrétisé lui même
dans son bulletin de citoyens colombey
les deux églises
et le premier ministre monsieur michel
debré à montlouis à bordeaux c'était le
oui du président de l'assemblée monsieur
chaban delmas dans le jura le oui les
radicaux par la voix de ben arfa si à
marseille le oui de monsieur de fer se
nuance est à arras monsieur guy mollet
apporter leurs idées socialistes comme à
lille monsieur maurice schumann le oui
du mrp
le bulletin de monsieur torres n'était
pas des réserves des communistes et
celui de monsieur pin et de celle des
indépendants
dans la nuit les tableaux du ministère
de l'intérieur ont suivi le déroulement
du dépouillement 17 millions 500 mille
oui pour 19 millions 300 mille suffrages
exprimés et il monsieur roger frey
pourrait annoncer aux journalistes le
record des ouïes près de 91%
voyage éclair à turin le général de
gaulle poursuivant ses pourparlers avec
les nations voisines est allé
s'entretenir avec le chef du
gouvernement italien monsieur fanni
[Musique]
les deux hommes d'état au cours de leur
examen des problèmes internationaux se
sont surtout attachés à rapprocher leurs
points de vue sur la formation de la
future europe politique si leur tête à
tête n'a pas donné officiellement de
résultats concrets on voit poindre
maintenant entre l'europe intégrée et
l'europe des batteries un espoir de
compromis
[Musique]
détente dans les relations franco
égyptienne le colonel nasser a libéré
les diplomates français que contre toute
justice il avait fait traduire devant
ces tribunaux monsieur mattei et ses
compagnons donc retrouvés à orly leurs
familles paris et le caire vont ils
renouvellent leur relation interrompue
et l'algérie nouvelle commence à
s'organiser aura chez noir monsieur
christian fouchet haut-commissaire de
france a installé l'exécutif provisoire
dans le président est monsieur
aberrahmane farès qui fut autrefois
président de l'assemblée algérienne la
distribution des responsabilités
maintenant officiel les douze
commissaires ont pris possession de
leurs fonctions et le président du
nouvel organisme a ouvert la première
séance de travail
[Musique]
enfin
ça fait
le fond des mers livrera-t-il bientôt
ses secrets c'est avec l'ambition de les
lui arracher en tout cas que le super
bathyscaphe archimède de la marine
française s'est embarqué à toulon très
prosaïquement du reste sur le carreau
maori destination yokohama japon là bas
il entreprendra des essais qui nous
conduiront entre 10 et 11 mille mètres
de profondeur sous le pacifique
aux états unis on vise plus haut la lune
exactement la future capsule du projet
apollon qui sera occupé non plus par un
mais par trois astronautes ce qui leur
permettra de moins s'ennuyer a été
présentée très officiellement le système
d'alimentation par pub a lui aussi été
expérimenté tout simple paraît il reste
il est vrai à mettre au point la fusée
est le moteur qui permettront non
seulement d'alunir mais de repartir quoi
qu'il en soit on nous promet la lune
pour 1968
[Musique]
ala cimaises de la galerie david et
garnier paris affronté récemment une
scène peu orthodoxes ou judas tourner le
dos au christ et aux autres à pau ils
découvraient ainsi un nouveau buffet un
buffet mystique à la suite des matisse
le corbusier cocteau le jeune peintre
abordait à son tour l'art sacré à sa
manière en noir jaune et rouge
on aime ou on n'aime pas cette peinture
sombre et brutal on fut d'accord portant
sur la prodigieuse faculté d'envoûtement
de ces visages tragique
cette exposition avait aussi une autre
signification elle soulignait
l'extraordinaire réussite du mari
d'annabelle
[Musique]
à 32 ans il s'offrait le luxe d'exposer
des toiles dont chacune aurait pu être
acheté des millions et dont aucune
n'était avant 15 ans ont suffi pour en
arriver là
autour des années 48 bernard buffet
n'était encore qu'un adolescent inconnu
qui flânaient devant notre-dame et sur
qui personne ne se retournait
c'était le temps du petit bistrot où les
habitués le patron bienveillant et
bourru accueillait gentiment ce garçon
qui barbouillent l étoile dans le
quartier un jour peut-être pourquoi pas
on parlerait de lui mais dans combien
d'années dans la peinture qu'il le sait
le temps des oeufs durs peut aussi bien
durer toute une vie moins de quinze ans
séparent pourtant le bistrot des
batignolles est la propriété de château
l'arc près d'aix en provence
bernard buffet et annabelle comme
picasso à 80 ans sont devenus chaplin au
milieu de leurs bibelots d'un courrier
qui arrivent des quatre coins du monde
ils se sont réservés à luxe
supplémentaire le bistrot reconstitué du
temps tout proche où la gloire et la
fortune d'aujourd'hui n'étaient même pas
imaginable
le château le parc le chenil pelles sont
aujourd'hui les signes d'une réussite
foudroyante dont on aimerait penser
qu'elle est un peu la revanche des
peintres voué à la misère d'un gauguin
d'un vent d'oc d'un maudit guyenne
[Musique]
les sportifs américains honteuse aussi
leurs hommes de l'espace cet homme c'est
le sauteur à la perche john huston on ne
sait pas s'il ya des limites aux
exploits de cet athlète qui a frisé 5
mètres à plusieurs reprises son record
du monde 4 m 89 exactement il est vrai
que la perche qui l'utilisent ressemble
étrangement à une catapulte
pour le racing club de paris en maillot
blanc culotte noire et pour
saint-etienne ce match du parc des
princes et le match de la dernière
chance le racing joue le titre de
champion de france quant à saint-etienne
il joue son maintien actuellement fort
compromis en première division
très entreprenant maniant la contre
attaque avec beaucoup de verve les
stéphanois prennent avantage sur un tir
de riches versent
tout cela un peu contre le cours du jeu
le racing en effet pratiquer un football
beaucoup plus collectif le ballon voyage
d'un joueur à l'autre il est vrai
cependant que toutes les actions des
parisiens manquent de vitesse
ils parviennent cependant à égaliser
dix 2e mi temps rien ne change le racing
domine outrageusement et de temps à
autres saint-etienne contre attaque
comme en ce moment trois relais de balle
successifs et c'est suffisant aux
stéphanois pour marquer un second but et
gagner ainsi un match qui leur permet
d'attendre l'avenir avec un peu moins
inquiet
lorsque les allemands se met la bague au
doigt ce n'est pas du jour pour le bon
motif à preuve les munichois sont très
friands de ce genre d'exercice c'est
très présent comme spectacle en
spectacle plein de situations cocasses
et pourtant tout ceci est fort sérieux
il s'agit ici d'un championnat officiel
ce sport n'exige pas de qualités
intellectuelles particulière il suffit
de mettre son doigt dans un anneau et de
tirer du plus fort qu'on peut jusqu'à ce
que l'adversaire large pris
de bons muscles et une certaine capacité
de résistance à la douleur voilà les
qualités qu'il faut pour faire un
champion
tous les moyens sont permis à condition
que la table les tabourets soit assez
solide solide également doivent être les
concurrents qui risquent souvent la
chute voilà qui est il paraît qu'il ya
tout de même à vainqueur il ya des
subtilités qui nous échappe
[Musique]
le conseil constitutionnel a par la voix
de son président monsieur léon noël
donné les résultats officiels du
référendum
[Applaudissements]
ce scrutin clôture est une phase de la
vème république et le général de gaulle
a accepté la démission du premier
ministre le président de la république
l'a chaudement remercié de ses efforts
et de son dévouement pendant les 3 ans 3
mois et 6 jours de son gouvernement et
l'on a vu à michel debré détendus et
souriants
quelques heures plus tard le général de
gaulle nommé au poste de premier
ministre monsieur georges pompidou le
nouveau chef du gouvernement s'est
immédiatement mis en devoir de former un
ministère qui comprenait moins de
techniciens et davantage de politiques
et à l'hôtel matignon entre messieurs
michel debré et georges pompidou s'est
déroulée dans une cordiale atmosphère la
transmission des pouvoirs un chapitre
nouveau va s'ouvrir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le jugement de l'ex général jours
sera-t-il dramatique épisode qui
pleurera une période féconde en
événements dramatiques la crise
algérienne on a pu mettre des noms sur
les visages des protagonistes de ce
douloureux procès
le député algérien robert abdessalam
l'ex directeur de l'écho d'alger
monsieur alain de série ni un membre du
tribunal monsieur pasteur de léry raddho
le général allard
madame albert camus madame jouer petite
ombre perdu dans l'ombre des couloirs
enfin le président barney qui dirigeait
les débats
sortant de la voiture cellulaire qui
l'amenait de la santé l'ex général
jouhaud qu'attendait au terme de trois
journées de dramatique péripéties la
condamnation à mort
a alger la série des plasticages a
continué au compte de l'organisation de
l'armée secrète on devait notamment
porter l'explosion qui a rendu
inutilisable la tour de contrôle de
l'aéroport de maison blanche
[Applaudissements]
le trafic aérien toutefois prise en
charge par les services de guidage
militaire n'a pas été interrompue
[Musique]
la pointe de l'île de la cité à l'ombre
de notre dame une crypte garde désormais
le souvenir de deux cent mille français
morts en déportation
le général de gaulle en présence de
monsieur michel debré et de nombreuses
personnalités a inauguré cette tombe
symbolique les deux cent mille martyrs
de l'exil
en se recueillant devant le déporter
inconnu c'est le tribut de la nation qui
a porté le général de gaulle à ceux qui
sont obscures et mans nord pour elle
dans la détresse des camps et dont la
destinée s'inscrit dans cette devise
désespérés ils allèrent à l'autre bout
de la terre et ils ne sont pas revenus
saint sébastien a subi les assauts de la
galère ce vent d'ouest nord ouest des
côtes atlantiques et le spectacle qui ne
manquait pas de grandeur auraient été
perdus si une caméra n'avait pas été là
lancée à la poursuite des rares voitures
qui s'était aventuré sur le paseo nuevo
les vagues déchaînées poussèrent leurs
assauts jusqu'à l'intérieur de la ville
il en faut davantage bien sûr pour qu'on
se trouve la saint sébastien mais tout
de même on ne voit pas cela tous les
jours
[Musique]
c'était simple il fallait y penser un
miroir parapluie concentrent les rayons
solaires sur une sphère laquelle libère
des vapeurs de mercure qui alimente une
turbine et l'énergie solaires assurent à
deux minuscules réacteur une poussée de
20 grammes moyennant quoi phaéton le
futur satellite français placés sur une
première orbite pour à lui-même sans
choisir une autre
en attendant la construction de la fusée
qui le lancera feuilleton a tout de même
voyagé il fera les beaux jours de
l'exposition de lanobre simple début
[Musique]
encore de satory un autre engin à venir
a été révélée à la curiosité le véhicule
français à effet de sol comme disent les
techniciens c'est à dire capable de se
mouvoir sur un coussinet d'air comprimé
et ce n'est pas une mince révolution
quand il songe nous vivons depuis des
millénaires sur une invention de génie
la room et voici qu'on nous propose une
civilisation sans roues
[Musique]
un conducteur d'un deux roues à moteur
dit la sagesse des nations est sur la
route un élément parfois dangereux mais
toujours sans défense c'est être sujet à
toutes les chutes ne se protéger même
pas la tête
la loi doit d'y mettre bon ordre
aujourd'hui le casque est obligatoire
mais tout de même pour n'importe quel
casque
[Musique]
pas celui ci dont la pointe paratonnerre
et peu convaincant
à celui ci non plus un peu trop
décoratifs pour l'époque que nous vivons
quant à ce dernier en dépit des
garanties qu'il of il semble quand même
un peu dépassé non le casque obligatoire
est un casque étudié uniquement pour les
chocs à la tête apte à protéger selon
les normes les plus protectrices la
boîte crânienne de son possesseur
à preuve les essais de résistance de
tout ordre imposé à ses coiffures auquel
tout médiocrité est absolument interdit
[Musique]
un casque établi en vue de la protection
doit absolument protéger reste que de
mauvais esprit parleront d'élégance
méconnu de dignité méprisés arrêtons les
du prince philippe à la reine
d'angleterre et au président de la
république que de nobles front n'ont pas
craint de porter ce qu'on peut à juste
titre a péri si un couvre chef
et puis quelle sécurité et même en
dehors des dangers de la route
est ce que le casque de motocycliste ne
deviendrait pas avec facilité tout
simplement la coiffure d'extérieur
[Musique]
et
même d'intérieur
[Musique]
c'est dans un palais des sports archi
comble à bruxelles que pierre kosmin se
met en jeu son titre de champion
d'europe des poids coq devant l'italien
piero rollo sûr de lui le boxeur belge
culotte blanche attaque d'entrée sans
laisser à son adversaire le temps de
souffler ces deux boxeurs sont rapides
et mordant comme s'il avait encore 20
ans et pourtant ils ont dépassé tous de
la trentaine cos mince à 31 ans rouleau
35 ans il est vrai que dans cette
catégorie les boxeurs sont ordinairement
très agressif quel que soit leur âge et
puis les choses se gâtent rôle on trouve
l'ouverture un crochet du gauche
fulgurant au col estomac cei
ins masse n'est plus champion d'europe
il a fallu un peu plus de 12 minutes
pour en arriver là c'est un moment
terrible pour un boxeur il a mal il ne
peut plus rien d'autre que de pleurer
ses illusions perdues
pour roland c'est le triomphe et c'est
alphonse halimi qui lui remet sa
ceinture de champion d'europe
[Applaudissements]
les rugbymen français en maillot clair
on jouer à quitte ou double contre
l'irlande dans le tournoi des six
nations la chance aidant ils ont
parfaitement tenu leur pari dès le début
du match et c'est demont déjà transformé
par albaladejo après quelques minutes de
jeu 5 à 0
et puis tout s'est arrêté là on n'est
pas sorti de la grisaille pendant de
très longs moments on a beaucoup couru
de part et d'autre sans soulever
l'enthousiasmé des 40000 spectateurs de
colombes fort heureusement les irlandais
n'ont pas baissé les bras ils ont même
donné un peu de piment à la rencontre en
jouant avec beaucoup d'application
et ce n'est qu'en fin de partie que les
françaises sont décidés vraiment à
montrer ce qu'ils avaient fait
cette attaque qui amène le deuxième
essai à maudire
le festival offensif de la france
poursuit mais on regrette qu'il ait
fallu attendre le dernier quart d'heure
pour assister à des actions
spectaculaires finalement 11 à 0 pour
les français et la victoire dans le
tournoi des six nations
algérie europe tels ont été les deux
sujets qu'avec monsieur louis joxe un
ancien gaston palewski un nouveau edgard
pisani un ancien monsieur georges
pompidou étudier au cours de son premier
conseil des ministres le premier conseil
des ministres du deuxième gouvernement
de la vème république
de monsieur alain peyrefitte à jacques
mayol on appuyait cette occasion
découvrir les neuf nouveaux visages de
l'équipe gouvernementale neuf nouveaux
visages qui ne sont pas tous inconnus
puisque le gouvernement compte messieurs
pierre pflimlin et maurice schumann
le général salan que l'on connu comme le
général le plus décoré de l'armée
française est aujourd'hui arrêté puis en
la france il s'était un temps installé
en espagne et il y avait réuni les
premiers fils d'une conjuration se
proposait de soulever l'algérie cette
conjuration de manas au putsch du 22
avril ou du balcon de la délégation
générale il a parlé pour haranguer la
foule on sait comment ce terminal
aventure
caisse pire est il de son action
terroriste dans une algérie las de tant
de sang répandu et d'une france qui
avait donné au général de bull lobby
mastic du référendum aujourd'hui c'est
la fin l'ex-général ça n'en était
conduit la santé derrière les murs de sa
prison le chef de l'oas attend 6 juin
[Musique]
en angleterre on prépare activement pour
le marché comme la sortie de la voiture
à turbine ce prototype vient de partir
pour les états unis où l'on compte qu'il
se fera également remarque le conducteur
n'aura plus que deux pédales actionnées
l'accélérateur et le frein mais surtout
plus de cylindres plus de piston plus de
carburateur
un progrès dans le sens de la
simplification
[Musique]
dans le domaine de l'aviation
l'angleterre encore vient de présenter
un nouveau modèle dont l'ambition est la
vitesse le bristol 188 a été construit
en acier inoxydable pour lui permettre
de franchir le mur de la chaleur après
le mur du son et du même coup de
s'offrir une vitesse égale à trois fois
la vitesse du son
[Musique]
il faut donner un souvenir ému à pierre
larquey qui dans sa villa de maisons
laffitte vient de s'éteindre à soixante
dix huit ans après avoir personnifié
dans 250 lui mais plus la gentillesse la
bonne amie la tendresse humaine qu'il
incarnait aussi dans la vie
par vous alors votre poêle georges le
grand père du cinéma n'est plus
[Musique]
toute l'espagne pendant la semaine
sainte célèbrent la passion du christ
non madrid la nuit du vendredi une
longue procession parcours
statut porté sur des chars illuminés
litan à cagoule porteur de cierges
réalit comme au siècle passé cette
passion qui chez les chrétiens le sommet
religieux de l'année
[Musique]
en italie près de naples les paysans du
village de nola seront honorés au sommet
d'une colline d à peine notre dame des
sept douleurs ces pèlerins ont fait le
voeu dilué de chapelle à la madone
vénéré et par centaines les femmes en
forme de pénitence y apportent leur
pierre
tradition émouvante mais qui laisse
perplexe n'y a t'il la bac les femmes
qui pêche ou qui se rapporte
on savait que la profession d'honneur
c'était dignement honoré en grande
bretagne vous ne savez peut-être pas que
l'exigeait des capacités sportives
particulière mais ce ne peut être que
dans un louable esprit d'émulation qui
était organisé dans le comté d'essex
cette course de voitures d'enfants nous
fait remarquable mais qui ne doit plus
nous surprendre l'époque des femmes
soldats
les concurrents masculins étaient amis
14 km 400 à couvrir et à leur terme une
heure de gloire pour ceux et celles qui
étaient parvenus à mener à bon port
matériel et chargement
à peine sortis de leur voiture les
enfants américains ceux du moins des
maradona russe en sont déjà à
s'expliquer sur un ring avec aux mains
des gants gros comme la tête
par ces temps de guerre froide endémique
il n'est sans doute pas mauvais de
laisser librement la combativité se
révéler dès le plus jeune âge et la
preuve est faite en tout cas que les
jeunes générations ne mentent pas reste
que le métier de parent n'apparaît pas
après ses démonstrations comme devant
être des plus tranquilles
[Applaudissements]
la neige d'avril qui aura permis cette
année de prolonger les sports d'hiver
jusqu'à pâques nous a valu de rencontrer
dans les alpes à un skieur dont le moins
qu'on puisse dire est qu'il a une
technique très personnelle jaloux
tournier voyez plutôt
[Musique]
sa technique pour n'avoir aucun rapport
avec celle de l'oeuf cher à nos
champions n'en garde pas moins une
efficacité certaine encore que
déroutante
cet acrobate des neiges a aussi plus
d'un tour dans son sac
[Musique]
m
on
avec jeannot tournier sans doute faut-il
ne s'étonner de rien
[Musique]
après cela que voulez vous il faudra
bien se dire que tout sur l'éducation
est à refaire et dans le commencement
[Musique]
c'est un simple village de la campagne
tourangelle quelques vieilles fermes
abandonnées
mais on peut dormir dans les greniers
pour peu qu'on s'arme contre les rats et
qu'on s'arrange d'un confort sommaire il
ya maintenant cinq ans trois jeunes
femmes se tard ce raisonnement et
abandonnant à la fois l'école des
beaux-arts et la vie parisienne var
s'installer à la martinerie et depuis on
peut voir chaque matin l'une ou l'autre
vaquer aux besoins de la communauté
ce fut d'abord un mystère pour les gens
du pays puis on s'habitue à ont compris
que les trois demoiselles de la
martinerie comme on les appelle n'était
pas venu là sur un caprice mais qu'elle
était venue chercher un refuge pour
leurs travaux
pour le matin elle commence à tirer
leurs chevaux car ils se sont voués à un
art très ancien la tapisserie à
l'éguille et en cinq ans de geste
patients identiques à ceux qui au moyen
âge ont donné la tapisserie de bayeux
elles ont redonné assez tard une
nouvelle gloire
[Musique]
le résultat de leurs travaux orne
aujourd'hui les murs d'une galerie
parisienne et c'est communal de proposer
aux hommes emportés par la vie moderne
au travers de sujets aussi simple que le
bien et le mal la lumière et les
ténèbres la sagesse et l'amour
les demoiselles de l'usiné ont renoué
avec l'inspiration des fresques romanes
et des mosaïques byzantines
et donner à leurs oeuvres cette grâce
inimitable la vie
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]